[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us
for more than two decades an
organization in new york's harlem
neighborhood
has used figure skating to help girls
from underserved communities grow
physically emotionally
and academically we are meeting the
group and two young skaters
overcoming barriers on and off the ice
when i figure skit i just feel free
anything that happened before it just my
mind just
clears nine-year-old jade has been
skating for almost half her life
her mother says the sport has shaped her
daughter in countless ways
she never was shy but you know just a
little timid
after the first week she just kind of
just changed into a different girl
she's so confident now i did a project
on harriet tubman
and it was really fun jade is one of
thousands of girls whose lives have been
transformed by
figure skating in harlem an organization
founded in 1997.
the organization is more than just
skating you're realizing wow
that was hard and i learned how to do it
and i actually did it and i didn't think
i could
that carries on to anything else outside
of life
persistence not giving up that's really
the message that we send here
i had never known black girls to do
skating that was something that was
impossible to me i'd never heard of it
the program
delivers to you more than just like
skating girls like high school sophomore
vitoir
balanced school along with skating
practice at least twice a week
families apply and pay tuition on a
sliding scale
but no girl is turned away because of
money skates and lessons are included
in addition to specialized courses and
academic tutors
they're teaching you self-worth teaching
you confidence teaching your financial
literacy they're
teaching you to value your education get
the most you can out of it
are there figure skaters that you admire
that you look up to
first one who paved the way for
young black figure skaters is mabel
fairbanks
[Music]
forbidden the practice or compete
because of her race
mabel fairbanks taught herself on frozen
ponds and flooded tennis courts
she gave you courage strength
validity fairbanks coached a toy wilson
he was the first black figure skater to
compete he went on to win
a national title in 1966.
is there something poetic about the fact
that mabel fairbanks
fell in love with figure skating in
harlem
and there's now this organization in
harlem
teaching young and brown girls
to see this link really paying homage
to the trailblazing people such as mabel
fairbanks on ice she was alone by
herself
out there but had the distinction and
tenacity
and the enthusiasm
as it is in a relationship of seeing
the girls with figure skating in harlem
going to competitions and seeing that
we were the only majority black team
our coaches always reinforcing in us you
worked hard to get here
i work hard to be in these spaces i
deserve to just
to feel just as beautiful and just as
elegant
over the past five years 100 of the
students in the program
went on to college alumni have become
successful lawyers
teachers photographers and entrepreneurs
what are some of the lessons
that you learned here that you'll pick
up
long after you've left this program and
you turn up in a board room and you're
the only black executive there
my family has made me strong my
community has made me strong i have made
myself strong and i choose to be strong
in the spaces that i choose to be in any
room that i walk into i know i have
something special
to give
[Music]
back in 2018 beyonce's ivy park
sportswear line honored figure skating
in harlem because
quote these girls embody our motto
strong beyond measure 250 girls in that
program wow
they have a smaller program in detroit
they've helped a lot of people uh learn
to skate and
improve themselves and did you know
about mabel fairbanks no i didn't
ever heard it are they called arlen's
wonder girl that's right harlem's wonder
girl she was uh she was a mentor to a
lot of
young skaters including a toy who just
met in the piece but also
stars like thai babylonia and christie
yamaguchi why don't we know her name
that's a good question i'm i'm a little
concerned vlad's trying to filibuster me
here because he knows
that i am in possession of some video of
you trying to skate
and i want to show that now and ask if
you were at all nervous
they are very good teachers they are
very that is awesome
that was my first time ever on the ice
you go vlad yes and
jade was there and vitoir was there to
make sure i didn't fall they were
holding my hand
the entire time i was expecting us when
they we saw that chorus line of girls
skating on the ice i was expecting a
slow pan across the girls and then
vlad yes i kept thinking you were going
to come up but you didn't
the real person our producer vida who's
sitting right behind me she's an amazing
serious thinker
serious skater right that's right you
look a little like nana it's a great
degree
to make fun of him a great piece and a
great program vlad thank you very much